vamos a dividir 350 entre 50 una forma
de pensar en esto es imaginar que
tenemos 350 cosas de algo muy bueno no
sé se me ocurren 350 pastelitos si
tenemos 350 pastelitos y si los
dividimos en grupos de 50 cuántos grupos
de 50 vamos a tener una idea es contar
de 50 en 50 hasta llegar a 350 y ver
cuántos grupos fueron un grupo de 50
serán 50 más otro grupo de 50 serán 100
más otros 50 tendremos 150 más otros 50
serán 200 más 50 250 más 50 300 más
otros 50 350 cuando sumamos todos estos
grupos de 50 nos va a dar 50 100 150 200
250 300 350 tenemos 350 así que 350 es
lo mismo que todos
estos grupos de 50 cuántos grupos
tenemos aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 así que 350
dividido entre grupos de 50 es igual a 7
ahora veamos con cuidado esta solución
de 7 y noten algo si dividiéramos 35 en
grupos de 5 también nos hubiera dado 7
35 dividido en grupos de 5 también es
igual a 7 así que de cierta forma estos
ceros no importan no afectan a nuestra
respuesta
pudimos cancelar los el tener el 0 en la
primera posición o la posición de las
unidades nos permite cancelarlo con el
otro 0 que se encuentra también en la
primera posición o en la posición de las
unidades en este otro número veamos por
qué es esto la división realmente es lo
mismo que una fracción si escribimos
esto como una fracción 350 sobre 50
esta barra de fracción de aquí es lo
mismo que este signo de división aquí
arriba 350 dividido entre 50 es lo mismo
que 350 sobre 50 y cuando tenemos una
fracción como este podemos simplificar
la y en este caso como tenemos ceros al
final en ambos números sabemos que ambos
números son múltiplos de 10 así que
podemos dividir ambos / 10 / nuestro
numerador y nuestro denominador entre 10
y cuando dividimos números enteros entre
10 tenemos un truco que podemos usar o
mejor dicho un patrón y es que el número
completo en este caso 350 cuando lo
dividimos entre 10 quitamos un cero al
final 350 dividido entre 10 es igual a
35 350 puede dividirse en 35 grupos de
10 cuando dividimos 50 entre 10 le vamos
a quitar el último 0 otra forma de
pensar en ello
si tenemos 50 y lo dividimos en grupos
de 10 nos quedarán 5 grupos y terminamos
con la fracción simplificada de 35 sobre
535 quintos ó 35 dividido entre 5 que es
lo que tenemos aquí arriba así que
podemos ver que en ambos casos es lo
mismo 350 entre 50 es igual a 35 entre 5
así que en ambos números enteros
terminan en 0
podremos cancelar ambos ceros
básicamente estamos factor izando el 10
dividimos ambos números entre 10 así que
cancelamos ambos ceros lo que nos deja
con unas cantidades más pequeñas para
hacer la división y al menos para mí es
mucho más sencillo dividir cantidades
pequeñas
hagamos otros ejemplos digamos que
tenemos 420 dividido entre 70
vemos que tenemos dos números enteros
ambos terminan en cero por lo que vamos
a cancelar esos ceros
básicamente dividimos entre 10 ambos
números y nos quedamos con un problema
de división más sencillo 42 entre 7 42
entre 7 es igual a 6
por lo tanto 420 entre 70 también va a
ser igual a 6 hagamos un último ejemplo
qué tal si tuviéramos 5600 dividido
entre 80 lo primero que veo es que tengo
ceros al final de ambos números y son
números enteros
si canceló este 0 puedo cancelar uno de
los ceros de este otro número no puedo
cancelar ambos ceros aquí ya que sólo
puedo cancelar la misma cantidad de
ceros en ambas cantidades por lo que
ahora me va a quedar 560 entre 8 esto
nos deja con un nuevo problema de
división
sigue siendo un poquito más largo pero
no es tan complicado como el original y
podemos pensar en 560 como 56 decenas
debido a éste 0 al final y 56 decenas o
560 podemos reescribirlo como 10 por 56
estas son equivalentes 560 y 10 por 56
ya que 10 por 56 es lo mismo que 56 con
un 0 al final y si lo hacemos de esta
manera vamos a tener una división
todavía más sencilla 56 entre 8 que
podemos resolver 56 entre 8 es igual a 7
y seguimos teniendo este 10 que vamos a
multiplicar y 10 por 7 es igual a 70
por lo que nuestra solución cuando
dividimos 560 entre 8 es igual a 70 lo
que significa que nuestra solución aquí
arriba 5600 entre 80 también va a ser
igual a 70 ya que cuando cancelamos 0 si
dividimos seguiremos teniendo la misma
solución pero recuerden que debemos de
cancelar la misma cantidad de ceros en
ambos números aquí no pudimos cancelar
ambos ceros si cancelamos un 0 en el
dividendo podemos cancelar un 0 en el
divisor y otra cosa que debemos recordar
para este truco bueno lo primero que
debemos recordar es que tenemos que
cancelar la misma cantidad de ceros en
ambas cantidades y lo segundo que
debemos recordar es que los ceros deben
estar al final de estas cantidades si
tuviéramos un problema como 506 dividido
entre 20 aquí no podemos cancelar los
ceros ya que este cero no se encuentra
al final de esta cantidad así que 56
entre 2
es equivalente a 506 entre 20 estas
divisiones son diferentes así que no
podemos cancelar ceros a menos que se
encuentren al final de las cantidades y
debemos cancelar la misma cantidad de
ceros en el dividendo y en el divisor